- tell us your five scariest movies
other than the notebook notebook is
number one okay
so scary and then I would have to say
Evil Dead - really yeah because evil the
- isn't scary but it is a horror movie
something that really gets you like that
and shakes you that stirs you in in the
inside where you scream and you feel
like whoa like that did I feel unsettled
after watching that well a lot of it is
like it takes time made it not scary but
initially initially but if you're gonna
talk about like probably a raise your
head that's look I have it on my list is
top 10 probably Exorcist is definitely
on my list - another one was when I was
a kid my mom took me to see it I thought
it was the scariest movie I've ever seen
but in retrospect it's not Elephant Man
for how old were you I was a kid yeah
exactly there's a lot of I didn't know
was a true story
you know what alpha Manas I said it's in
the poster I don't know anything
so Elephant Man was a guy by my name of
John Merrick it's a true story and he
had elephantitis of the face he's a
whole body
so he's mutated or whatever was it quick
and I just say are you smiling at my all
my family members used to say my penis
at elephantitis because the foreskin
continued [ __ ] you cousins yeah hey yeah
elephantitis come here when we make
money that's the first thing we're gonna
do is fix your dick cosmetic surgery
totally I could do this [ __ ] I've been
offering to do that [ __ ] for free for a
while half a million followers I'm doing
book book style it's so funny because
the two movies are scary as David Lynch
movies so Elephant Man elephant
yeah and Anthony Hopkins is in it and
it's it's black and white it's very kind
of Moody and scary in that way and um
what else is scary but those modder
these modern ones that are coming out
yeah I mean ice cream and I think the
cot the second conjuring was scary cuz
pretty scary
first one scary first insidious I
thought was pretty scary you know
another scary one was
and I'm sorry to say his ring oh hell
yeah my mom and I and my brother saw the
ring at the ArcLight
and we always left like there was one
point where we stood up and we were
leaving we hated it that much
he was so scary no the I think the
original ring who is pretty scary - yeah
Ringo was president I thought the
American version was very scary though
yeah it was by the way there's already
like you like that that the sound of the
videotape VHS whole thing yeah the whole
thing was scary you guys don't care
about saw films right those do nothing
no and if any of any film where you're
being tortured no yeah but you see
what's what makes me most afraid is
anything that involves like possessions
because that's what we were told to
believe supernatural anything like
ghosts and spirits that possess a human
body those are the most like the Emily
Rose one that's why the conjuring once
you're scary to me The Exorcist those
are ones that really [ __ ] me up
but I thought remember the law orphan at
the orphanage guillermo del toro yeah
and what I thought the audition was
pretty scary with a chicken wire that
gave me nightmares a cream oh yeah yeah
that was very scary yeah I think those
are those are my top ones oh you know
what the Night of the Living Dead but
the remake of the 90s with a redhead was
really scary to me it was not the
original Night of the Living Dead they
remade it as like 1990 or something and
they cast as like short had a short
haired red redheaded uh-huh and I think
maybe it's cuz I was really young again
like when you said like when you're
really young it's really scary I trained
at Busan was scary it was scary to me it
was just good it's just fun to watch
yeah you rod right you're yelling at the
audio yeah you know I like that but
nothing's really you know and these
other movies that we're talking about
the newer ones like insidious and stuff
they do tricks like you know shuck
tricks yeah you know like in don't breed
the dog out of nowhere attacking the
glass yeah you Yelp because it's
shocking or like Lila it doesn't
linger with you yeah for me I have any
time the voice like changes yeah that's
what the any demonic voice I'll punch
you any demonic voice I can't do and any
type of just possess any anytime anyone
is possessed I can't deal with it in
omen - I remember omen but in an omen -
there's a scene where Damian who's the
son of the devil is in school there's a
scene where the history teacher says
like you know everything and so he's
just throwing like when did this happen
when did this happen he knew all the
answers it's really very scary scene
because it's the devil he knows
everything 1908 thank you yeah stuff
yeah and as a yeah yeah oh you know it
was a good one was babadook yeah that
was very good very good one I think the
scariest though is 108 stitches
yeah dad fans on it it's a baseball
movie we need Albert
[Music]